- It was 1997.
I was 14 years old and she was
my best friend's girlfriend.
What it a dick move?
Yes.
But, to be fair, I kissed her first.
It was like the previous summer,
I'm hanging out with Mike and Jen.
And Mike and me are best
friends, we hang out a lot.
He's got AOL online.
Jen and Mike aren't dating yet,
we're all just hanging out
at Jen's place watching MTV.
Mike falls asleep on the couch,
Jen and I are getting closer.
You know we start holding
hands, leads to kissing and
more kissing and then me
putting my hand under her shirt.
I, you know, thing something's
going to happen but it never does.
I just didn't articulate that we should
be dating, just couldn't say it.
And then she ends up dating Mike
because Mike is older than me.
And they were the same age and if you're
the same age you should be dating, right?
What's the deal with that?
Mike was a Seinfeld thing.
So they start dating
over my eight grade year.
I get to my emo phase, I hit
puberty, that's cool, sort of.
That summer my brother Patrick and Mike
get caught shoplifting at the Walmart.
And his parents are pissed.
He gets grounded for two months.
He can't leave the house,
he can't use the telephone.
So Jen and I are left alone
like the trio is broken up.
And I talk to Jen on the phone a lot
and then one day was like,
"Hey can I come over?
I'm just bored."
So we hang out at my
place, I don't have cable,
it's not that fun so
we're just getting close.
We're holding hands,
we're stroking thighs.
It's then that I know, oh man,
I can have sex for the
first time in my life.
It's possible.
I can't let this opportunity pass me by.
So I go and get a condom
from my Dad's sock drawer.
It's a Lifestyles condom.
I guess it's weird in it's
the same prophylactics
that my Dad was using to
have sex with my Mother.
Jen and I just walk 45 minutes back
to her place, it's like five miles.
I've got my best outfit on; beige Vans,
my citrus orange shorts,
and my lime green shirt.
I've got my black MTV baseball cap.
I look super cool.
Car beeps at us, I can only assume
that is was because I
looked like an idiot.
We get to her house, nobody's there.
We go to her Mom's bedroom
and we start watching HBO.
Making out, one thing leads to another,
I was like you know
what, I think it's time,
I'm going to pull out this condom.
Do you want to, and she says, "yeah okay".
She rips open the condom with her teeth.
That was cool in my mind.
That was like whoa, that's cool.
That's erotic.
Couldn't figure out
how to put on a condom.
Anyway, put it on, we get to love making.
I call it love making because yes,
I was in love and I was
doing this for love.
I'm a gentleman and I've got
older male friends who've
told me the things that you should do
to treat a lady to a nice time.
But none of us achieve climax.
I didn't ask her but I can only imagine
she didn't and I know that I didn't.
Like we're done, I go to pee.
I also look at myself in the
mirror like, who am I now?
What have I become?
Am I a good person, am I a man now?
I mean was I expecting to have a mustache?
I don't know.
Mike, you know, isn't grounded
any more and they keep dating.
I'm like well, I guess
she doesn't love me.
It was heartbreaking to
see them together still.
You know, I think she told him.
I didn't tell him.
You know I wanted to tell the world,
I just went my sad little
way and went to high school.
Who know if I told her that I loved her
and that we should be dating
we could be married now.
Or not.
Don't have sex if you're not able to
communicate those feelings
and you're relying
on sex to do that for you.
(slow jazz music)